[Music]
hey guys in this video means some season
8 conference boilers that most of you
will be happy about but before that I'm
also bring your theory in Johnston be
killed and resurrected in the final
season of Game of Thrones and it won't
have anything to do with Mills Sanjay or
the Lord of Light this theory might
sound ridiculous but bear with me so who
will bring Jon Snow back to life this
time
before I explain it all let me just say
that it has something to do with brain
and dragon was okay dragon has the main
reason John went to meet Danny at first
place is a common name in Westeros for a
substance known as obsidian why is it so
special
along with Valyrian steel it's one of
the two known substances capable of
killing by walkers along with fire it's
also one of the two known substances
capable killing White's and most of it
can be found on Dragonstone Island
German glass is the main reason John
accepted a nice imitation at Dragonstone
in the first place in order to mine it
and make weapons from it since without
it the living probably would not stand a
chance against nat king and his large
army that same form of volcanic glass
will in his series save John's life in
the upcoming season we'll get there soon
in this theory of mine Jamie loses his
life he near the hands of a horde of
whites or in the hands of the knight
King himself basically John will be
stabbed by a white Walker and will be
left to die which is probably how the
episode in which this happens wouldn't
bring a speechless any shock here again
at this point Mel Sanji will likely be
long gone and no other it priest will be
around to save Jon this time however we
have brain stark and we have Jagan wise
general glass was a very important tool
to the children of the forest using it
to fashion weapons along for garden
secret is that the children actually
used it to create the White Walkers as a
weapon by transforming humans into them
by plunging a jungler shard in the
human's heart so it a revelation of John
us being the substance that turns men to
White Walkers is John going to become a
white Walker and that we kind of avoid
the death maybe even somehow defeat the
knight King or overthrow him that's an
interesting thought but no it's not what
happens in this theory however
dragonglass will be plunged it on Jon
Snow's heart and it will save him from
the certain death and from turning into
white basically John will be stabbed by
a white Walker and left to die but
before he dies and turns into white
brain will save John's life by
commanding someone probably Jaime
Lannister to plunge a journalist dagger
to John's heart at first a me or to
whomever bran gives this at first glance
ridiculous command we'll stop for a
moment to question if he's heard in Bell
but brain Wilden exists and with John
being on his last breath
that someone will decide to babe rains
command since there is nothing to lose a
German was dagger will be plunged into
John snows that heart and it will save
his life
how does brand know that this would
prevent John from dying and turning into
white instead of actually killing him
how do we even know this would work to
answer that let's get back in season six
Brennan Muir flee while horror holds the
door the tool soon after be almost
killed by heard whites if not for a
hoodie man and horse who came to brain
and mirrors rescue its then then
revealed that hooded man is in fact
brains uncle Benjen stark who went
missing during his last ranging benjin
later explained to brain what happened
and how he survived benjin recounting
when he was stabbed by a white Walker
and left to die the children of forest
found him and saved him from dying and
turning into white with the same process
that creates white walkers journalist
inserted into his heart to sum it up we
know that journalist plunged into a
dying man's heart after he's been
stabbed by a white Walker prevents him
from dying and turning into white we
also know that brain already knows this
information which might but just might
mean that we are going to see Brant
saving Stan's life with journalists in
the final season of Game of Thrones will
it be Jon Snow whose light brain is
going to save or will it be Samara main
character that I cannot say for sure but
in my opinion it will be either John or
Jamie who's going to be defeated by a
white Walker or even by the night king
himself and left to die maybe it's even
more likely to be Jamie then John taking
into consideration that Jamie doesn't
have superior fighting skills anymore
nor superb martial skills all of which
disappeared with Jamie's sword hand
Jimmy barely stood his ground against an
ordinary storage soldier in season five
and barely survived his encounter with
to the track in season 7 one can only
hope Jamie doesn't get anywhere close to
white Walker but if he does there's a
good chance he'd lose a duel and get
himself stabbed before someone such as
Brienne comes to his rescue
fortunately for Jamie the kid he pushed
at that window could possibly save his
life if he does in fact gets dead and
left to die brain start the kid Jamie
made a [ __ ] in his failed attempt now
saves Jamie from stern death reminding
us again why Game of Thrones is the best
series full of irony and complicated
character arcs whether it will be Jon
Snow or Jaime Lannister someone else
entirely who might be saved and kind of
resurrected by bran stark and journalist
one thing is certain it's possible and
brings a very wet so the good news is if
our favorite character does get gravely
wounded by a white Walker during a great
war against the night king it might not
be his or hers and just yet now that
you've been introduced to the story
let's get into some spoilers for the
coming into final season on Game of
Thrones in case you don't want to hear
any confirmed spoilers it's time for you
to close this video ok David not a
director of three episodes of season 8
basically director of half of the final
season recently shared some spoilers
regarding the last six episodes of Game
of Thrones a couple of days ago neither
answered some questions from the fans on
the game turn subreddit before we get
into spoilers let's firstly say that he
revealed that he is convinced that each
of the six episodes will be longer than
60 minutes which is a good news
historically an average episode range is
very little from season to season from a
low of 54 minutes 25 seconds in season 2
to a high of 56 minutes 8 seconds in
season 1 well season 7 leapt ahead with
its 63 minutes average although the
seven longer episodes of season 7 did
not make up for the missing 3 that all
the previous seasons of game interns had
before
these seven longer episodes did have
ever make up for one of them as screen
time of these seven was as long as eight
episodes from the previous seasons so
the fact that each episode of season
eight will be longer than 60 minutes is
not coming and expected one fan Dennis
Nutter if anything in season 8 will
generate the same level of shock and
heartbreak as those last few minutes of
nutters most well-known episode the
rains of castamere on which neither
replies and teases with as far as season
8 compared to the red wedding I just
have to tell you hang on to your seat
because it's going to be special the
reply to that probably explains the
statement the best it takes some guts to
say this basically if you were crying
over heartbroken during the red wedding
season it will do the same to you
although it's probably not going to be
just one episode but rather most of them
make sure to prepare some tissues before
the season a premiere which shares in
April 2019 less banana-leaf Schneider
also confirmed that we will see a dire
wolf in season 8 we all have dragons but
a dire wolves have also been a huge part
of the game appearance especially for
the stark children ghost has not been
seen ever since John was resurrected but
another dire wolf did appear in last
season although numerous brief
appearance did not make it up for the
little tune on screen time during this
past season at least we know that ghost
is alive and well and his at Winterfell
as the showrunners confirmed goes
through Maine that Winterfell with Sansa
and John left to meet Danny on
Dragonstone
according to the game insurance producer
Bryan cogman he wrote a scene featuring
ghost and show actually filmed the scene
with him for season 7 but I had to cut
it for budgetary reasons we were
supposed to see ghosts when John emerged
from the Winterfell crypts right
after he tried a little finger but
before he waved goodbye to Sansa so
summer in their ghost was supposed to
reappear
instead of ghost or sorrow the
showrunners decided to fulfill their
long waited wish of having an undead
barangay maternes
basically goes thrill has been cut twice
thus far
instead of goes the showrunners and the
director of episode battle the best
hurts also decided that it's better to
rather include a giant which in my
opinion was a good decision since I
don't see who else will be better in
breaching the gates of interval however
I'd be happier if instead of a vibe err
they included ghosts in season seven but
that's just me anyways the good news is
the game trans production has begin a
budget to include all things you'd like
to see in the final season hordes of
White's dragons Giants and of course
Devils it's not only been confirmed by
Nara that we are going to see dire wolf
in the final season but it's also been
confirmed by a visual effects supervisor
Joe Power who told The Huffington Post
that there's enough money now for
dragons and Giants and dire Wolf's and
much more he confirmed that ghosts will
be back and not just for a brief moment
as the media was in season 7 Bower said
oh you'll seem again he has a fair
amount of screen time in season 8 he
does show up
he's very present and does some pretty
cool things by doing some pretty cool
things I imagine ghosts killing bunch of
whites fighting alongside Jon Snow and
probably saving him hopefully without
having to sacrifice himself so Jon will
finally Rina if it goes probably early
on in the season and I'm sure we all are
eager to see ghost and is rolling what's
described as a fair amount of ghosts in
the final six episodes of Game of
Thrones about which I'm probably going
to talk more in the upcoming videos
ghost role probably will not be just
fighting against the night king and his
army
there's likely much more their walls
have since the very first episode been
tied up to the Starks and their fates
the main events of Game of Thrones
series have been foreshadowed by them
for example Ned Stark's death was
foreshadowed by the very first
appearance of durables as you'll
remember in the first episode of the
very first season Ned Stark accompanied
by John Robb Theon brain and a few other
men came upon a dead dire wolf a few
moments later we found out that this
devil was killed by a stag which
actually foreshadowed Robert Baratheon a
stag getting net the wolf killed by
inviting him to King's Landing and the
six pups that were left behind upon the
d'Arles that represents Ned six children
that were left behind Jon Snow spot for
share of Joshua lineage the outcast of
the pack as ghost was found apart from
the siblings in much the same way that
John as a bad
was apart from his own there can be seen
many more parallels and symbolism
between other die rolls and their master
star children such as aria sending the
merry off on her own to savor life which
is basically arias whole story being
forced to flee and be on her own in
order to survive
summers death on the other hand
symbolizes the end of summer winter is
here as well as the death of bran Stark
as we know him brain is not brain
anymore he is the three-eyed Raven now
there's much more of that about which
I'm going to talk in my upcoming videos
about importance of their walls and
their future roles so make sure to
subscribe it notification zone and stay
tuned and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next time peace
[Music]